Quelques jours avant leur suicide, le 30 avril 1945,
Adolf Hitler et Eva Braun finalisent
la destruction de toutes leurs archives.
Hitler ne veut rien laisser derrière lui.
Les historiens pensaient avoir consulté
toutes les archives existantes et accessibles.
70 ans plus tard, grâce à un officier français
aujourd'hui disparu, le commandant Raymond Rose,
Et à un collectionneur privé,
Ce sont de nouvelles archives politiques et
personnelles d'une importance historique,
Qui sont révélées pour la première fois.
Ces documents uniques permettent aujourd'hui
de mieux comprendre certains moments cruciaux,
Des derniers jours d'Hitler.
Quelle est l'atmosphère dans le bunker ?
Le Führer a-t-il encore l'espoir que
la situation militaire se retourne ?
Y a-t-il une preuve matérielle de la
liaison entre Hitler et Eva Braun ?
Quand décide-t-il exactement de
se suicider avec sa compagne ?
Goering souhaite-t-il vraiment prendre le
pouvoir dans les derniers instants du Reich ?
Le Troisième Reich vient d'être anéanti,
Berlin n'est plus qu'un champ de ruines.
Il ne reste plus rien de cette capitale qui a
fait trembler le monde pendant quelques années.
Les Occidentaux vont arriver et prendre possession de
leur zone d'occupation dans Berlin au mois de juin,
Et puis ils vont se précipiter pour visiter le bunker,
Vous avez des milliers de personnes
qui ont visité le bunker,
Et qui ont voulu voir ce que les Soviétiques
appelaient la tanière de la bête.
Tout le monde veut voir où Hitler est mort et il
va y avoir une succession de personnalités,
Et puis après des membres des forces d'occupation américains, anglais, français, soviétiques,
Qui vont venir visiter ce bunker.
Parmi les forces militaires qui visitent
le bunker, un groupe d'officiers français.
Le 25 novembre 1945, dans l'après-midi,
le commandant Raymond Rose,
Pénètre dans ce qu'il reste de la chancellerie
d'Hitler, par l'entrée principale de la rue Voss.
Ils ont préparé leur expédition.
Comme leurs camarades, qui les ont précédés,
ils espèrent y faire quelques découvertes.
Le commandant Rose a décrit son aventure dans les
sous sols du dernier quartier général d'Hitler.
Il a dessiné de sa main, trois plans de son itinéraire
et du lieu où il récupéra les documents du Führer.
De ce qui fut la chancellerie du Führer,
il ne reste que des murs,
Des salles vides encombrées de meubles renversés
et où la trace du pillage subsiste encore.
La maison s'offre à tout venant.
Dans la grande galerie, à la lueur des torches
électriques, il faut chercher une petite porte dérobée,
Et la pousser pour découvrir un escalier droit de
huit marches qui mène vers un second plus large,
Ce dernier donne accès à une
immense salle à colonnes carrées.
Bien qu'elle soit en sous-sol, cette pièce est décorée
avec le soin indispensable à toute pièce d'apparat.
C'est ensuite au fond de cette salle déjà obscure qu'il
faut découvrir une porte de fer à fleur de murailles,
L'ouvrir pour s'enfoncer sous terre par le moyen d'un escalier étroit et droit, il a exactement 26 marches.
On peut apercevoir un effroyable désordre de chaises
et de tables renversées, des taches de bougies,
Les traces d'un incendie qui n'a pas pu faire son œuvre.
Par terre, un incroyable amas de papiers de tous
genres, de tous ordres administratifs, de livres,
De cahiers fouillés par des mains qui, depuis sept mois,
S'acharnent à obtenir le secret que
l'invraisemblable bonne fortune m'a livrée.
C'est dans la pièce la plus reculée que
j'ai trouvé les documents qui établissent,
Qu'Hitler voulait rester quoi qu'il arrive, le maître
envers et contre tout, même contre les événements.
La petite troupe française fait une découverte
historique importante sans vraiment s'en rendre compte.
C'est un collectionneur français, passionné
par cette page sombre de l'histoire qui,
Plus de 70 ans plus tard, fait l'acquisition
des documents du commandant Raymond Rose.
Et un moment donné, il ramasse des documents qui étaient sur une armoire et il les ramène,
Et je dirais c'est juste après qu'il s'aperçoit de
la portée historique de ces documents,
Donc il demande l'autorisation pour
les conserver ce qui lui est accordé,
Et il a conservé ces documents toute sa vie,
Sachant qu'en plus, je pense qu'il
n'avait pas, lui, le recul de l'histoire.
Pour lui, c'était un acte beaucoup plus émotionnel puisqu'il était acteur de l'histoire d'une certaine manière.
Pour comprendre la portée inestimable
de ces documents historiques,
Il faut se replonger dans l'histoire
des derniers jours d'Adolf Hitler.
Mi avril, l'Armée rouge n'est plus qu'à
une centaine de kilomètres de Berlin.
Ce qui reste des divisions allemandes,
environ 500 000 hommes et 900 chars,
Reculent de toutes parts devant le rouleau
compresseur russe, le front cède sur 200 km.
Le Reich est exsangue et les Berlinois
subissent les bombardements aériens alliés.
Tous les dix jours, il y a un raid diurne
des Américains, mais toutes les nuits,
Il y a des raids de harcèlement des mosquitos britanniques.
Ce qui fait que la population est constamment
dans les escaliers et dans les caves,
En train de se réfugier dans les abris,
Hitler comme les 3 millions de Berlinois
et donc tout le monde est épuisé,
C'est d'ailleurs pour ça que les Anglais
multiplient ce genre de raids de harcèlement,
Et à un moment donné, la pression des bombardements
devient telle qu'il décide d'emménager,
Donc il s'installe définitivement dans le bunker.
Pour les Allemands désespérés, commence alors
l'interminable attente du dernier acte du drame.
À la radio a eu lieu l'ultime retransmission
en direct de l'Orchestre philharmonique de Berlin.
C'est le final du Crépuscule des
dieux, de Richard Wagner qui est joué.
Hitler s'enferme dans son abri à quelques
centaines de mètres de la porte de Brandebourg,
Sous les jardins de la Chancellerie,
dans le quartier central des ministères.
C'est depuis ce bunker qu'il dirige
ses dernières opérations militaires.
Pour mieux comprendre les plans de la
chancellerie et du bunker d'Hitler,
Ils ont été reconstitués en trois dimensions.
*
Dans la chancellerie d'Hitler, il
y a deux niveaux de bunker.
Le premier niveau a été construit en 1936
sous une partie de la chancellerie du Reich.
La deuxième partie a été construite à
partir de 1943, quand il est devenu clair,
Que le premier bunker avec un
plafond d'1m60 ne résisterait pas,
Aux bombes américaines et britanniques les plus puissantes.
Le bunker est une construction
relativement réduite par ses dimensions.
Sa superficie habitable a été sacrifiée aux dépens de la solidité. C'est un coffrage en béton absolument massif.
Hitler voulait être sûr de pouvoir rester à Berlin.
Il voulait pouvoir diriger les opérations depuis son bunker.
Après la tentative d'assassinat contre sa
personne et le coup d'État de juillet 1944,
Il avait peur de trop s'éloigner de
Berlin, le centre de tous les pouvoirs.
Hitler et Albert Speer, son architecte et ministre
de L'armement, ont pensé à tout pour ce bunker.
Le führer doit pouvoir y vivre un certain temps, entouré
de sa garde, à l'abri de toute attaque aérienne.
*
Dans cette partie du bunker, Hitler avait
fait prévoir un appartement séparé du reste.
Un appartement privé comprenant quatre petites pièces.
Dans l'autre partie du bunker, il y avait
plus de pièces, mais aucune intimité.
Hitler s'est réservé trois petites pièces
qui sont absolument minuscules,
Et une petite pièce attenante
pour sa maîtresse, Eva Braun.
Et tous les deux partagent une petite salle de bains.
On y trouve également une petite pièce
de réunion où deux fois par jour,
Hitler va assister à des points de situation
militaires avec ses principaux conseillers.
Le bunker est une cave enterrée
à sept mètres de profondeur.
Des aménagements spéciaux ont été apportés
pour le confort d'Hitler et de ses proches.
Évidemment, l'ambiance est lugubre, les lieux
eux-mêmes sont absolument lugubres,
Le coffrage en béton du bunker est en fait posé sur la nappe phréatique de la rivière Sprée qui coule pas très loin,
Donc c'est un endroit qui suinte l'humidité en permanence, le sol est en permanence pompé, il fait froid,
Il y a une ventilation artificielle mécanique,
On entend le bruit du ventilateur en
permanence, ça provoque des maux de tête.
C'est vraiment un endroit sordide.
Dans ce cadre, Hitler n'est pas au mieux de sa
forme, il multiplie les ordres contradictoires.
Son médecin, le docteur Morell, lui administre quotidiennement une injection de glucose et de vitamines.
Il prend plusieurs médicaments.
Tous les officiers qui ont rencontré Hitler à cette
époque, et j'en ai interviewé un certain nombre,
Ont tous été choqués de voir l'état
dans lequel était le Führer.
Sa main tremblait, il était livide et faisait au
moins entre dix et quinze ans de plus que son âge.
Ils étaient tous inquiets pour sa santé mentale.
Il est très délabré, il est effectivement
en état de Parkinsonisme avancé,
On voit bien il est courbé en deux, il traîne
des pieds, il ne contrôle plus son bras gauche,
Donc il doit le tenir avec sa main droite,
parce qu'il a des tremblements spasmodiques.
Pour faire fonctionner ce bunker, Hitler
dispose d'une trentaine de personnes,
Pour son service, sa garde personnelle, les techniciens
du bunker et les hommes chargés des communications.
Ce que vous avez là, c'est le dernier
rassemblement du Reich, c'est-à-dire,
Goebbels qui va emménager dans le bunker avec sa famille,
Bormann, le secrétaire, l'indispensable,
et puis les secrétaires.
Contre la volonté d'Hitler, sa compagne
secrète le rejoint dans le bunker.
Dans la collection privée que nous avons retrouvée se trouvent deux lettres extrêmement importantes d'Eva Braun.
Voici les exemplaires originaux, c'est
la première fois qu'ils sont révélés.
Ce sont ces deux dernières lettres.
La première est datée du 19 avril 1945,
Elle est adressée à sa meilleure amie,
Herta Schneider, qui est restée en Bavière.
Les secrétaires et moi, nous tirons chaque jour au
pistolet et nous sommes déjà de telles championnes,
Qu'aucun homme n'ose entrer en concurrence avec nous.
Ma vie ne se déroule pratiquement que dans l'abri aérien.
Tu peux t'imaginer que mon sommeil en souffre beaucoup.
Cependant, je suis très heureuse
d'être près de lui, justement maintenant.
Elle dit enfin, je vais rester avec lui.
C'est un peu tout le drame d'Eva Braun
d'être une petite fille, extrêmement romantique,
Qui était beaucoup plus jeune que lui et qui,
pendant toute la liaison qu'elle a eue avec Hitler,
N'a eu peur que d'une seule chose, c'est de le perdre.
Elle a tenté de se suicider, d'ailleurs, au début
de leur liaison, Hitler a pris peur et la conserver,
Et donc, c'est en fait quelque part pour
elle l'officialisation de sa liaison,
Et le fait de montrer qu'elle va
rester avec lui jusqu'au bout. Voilà.
Cette lettre nous donne également
des informations fondamentales,
Sur l'humeur d'Hitler à la veille de son 56ᵉ anniversaire.
Cette lettre est très intéressante pour
ça, elle montre l'ambiance du bunker,
On y voit encore certaines lueurs d'espoir.
Il est vrai qu'aucun jour ne passe sans que je
sois priée de me réfugier au Berghof, en Bavière.
Mais jusqu'à présent, c'est toujours moi qui ai gagné.
Dès aujourd'hui, toute communication est impossible,
Mais je suis profondément convaincue que tout va de nouveau tourner bien et lui est plein d'espoir plus que jamais.
Pourtant, à 3h du matin, le 20 avril,
une sirène lugubre retentit.
Une sirène que les Berlinois n'ont encore jamais entendu. Tous pressentent qu'un nouveau calvaire commence.
Des chars de l'Armée rouge sont signalés dans les faubourgs.
Donc le 20 avril est effectivement un moment clé puisqu'il voit symboliquement le jour de l'anniversaire d'Hitler,
Les Soviétiques commençaient à investir Berlin donc
le problème pour Hitler va se poser de savoir,
S'il reste dans la ville ou s'il fuit, ça,
c'est un problème très concret à partir du 20,
Puisque la menace d'encerclement est évidente, le dernier rideau de troupes s'est effondré.
Que faire ? Fuir ou se battre ?
À 15h ce jour là, Hitler fait sa
dernière sortie à l'air libre.
En haut des marches du bunker et
dans les jardins de la chancellerie,
Il reçoit les vœux d'anniversaire d'une délégation de SS.
Hitler reçoit notamment une délégation
des Jeunesses hitlériennes,
Parmi les plus jeunes des réserves de son armée.
Ce sont des enfants qui sont envoyés en
première ligne pour mourir en défendant Berlin.
Il tient à les honorer et récompenser
les plus courageux d'entre eux.
*
Le bras gauche d'Hitler est agité de tremblements.
Il serre la main de chacun, tapote la joue des plus
jeunes qu'il envoie à la mort au sein d'unités anti-char.
Le plus jeune a onze ans et demi, je ne
sais pas si vous vous rendez compte,
C'est un élèves de CM2 ou de sixième pour nous
aujourd'hui, il est tout petit, il doit faire 1m40,
Et il est en uniforme de la jeunesse hitlérienne.
À 16h, juste avant le point de la situation militaire,
Le Führer reçoit les vœux d'anniversaire
des hauts dignitaires de son parti,
Himmler, Ribbentrop, Bormann, Donitz,
Keitel, Jodl, Speer et Goering.
Tous les fidèles sont là, tout le monde le félicite.
Mais Hitler n'accepte tout cela qu'à contrecœur,
Parce qu'évidemment il n'est pas
d'humeur à célébrer son anniversaire.
Je pense que cette fête d'anniversaire du 20 avril 1945
est la plus grotesque que l'on puisse imaginer.
Ce matin là présent, vous aviez Goering, qui venait tout juste de faire exploser son château de Carinhall,
Pour qu'il ne tombe pas aux mains des Soviétiques.
Il était en transit dans Berlin avec
toutes ses cargaisons d'art volées.
Les tableaux et autres pièces étaient sur le point
d'être acheminées vers le sud, en Bavière,
Par des unités de l'armée de l'air.
Donc, il est présent à cet anniversaire avec
tous les dignitaires nazis comme Keitel.
Tous, attendent désespérément l'ordre
de Hitler de quitter Berlin.
Tous, savent aussi que la bataille est perdue d'avance.
Ils essayent de pousser Hitler à quitter
la ville pour se sauver eux mêmes.
Et ce jour là, sa maîtresse Eva Braun
lui offre un cadeau,
Une photo dédicacée.
Ce cadeau, nous l'avons retrouvé, jamais dévoilé
au public, c'est une pièce exceptionnelle.
Son histoire est rocambolesque.
Le cadre et sa photo sont restés après guerre,
pendant des années chez Gretl, la sœur d'Eva.
Il a fallu attendre que la famille Braun s'en sépare
pour qu'un amateur éclairé n'en fasse la découverte.
Cette dédicace est l'unique preuve matérielle
de l'amour qu'Eva Braun avait pour Hitler.
Tous les autres documents, comme leur correspondance privée, ont été détruits dans les derniers jours de la guerre.
Elle va lui offrir une photo d'elle
dédicacée dans un cadre en argent,
Qui porte en fait son monogramme qui est un
trèfle qui a été dessiné par Albert Speer.
Et cette photo comporte la dédicace suivante,
"À mon führer, en fidélité, ton Eva."
C'est très révélateur en fait de la mentalité
d'Eva Braun et de ce qu'elle cherche à avoir,
Puisqu'elle ne donne pas son prénom,
elle dit à mon Führer donc quelque part,
C'est une marque politique qui a de l'importance
et elle emploie surtout "en fidélité",
Et c'est vrai que c'est une époque où tout
le monde commence à partir dans tous les sens,
Et elle veut bien marquer en fait, sa fidélité à
Adolf Hitler et le fait qu'elle soit revenue, voilà.
Hitler accepte le cadeau de celle qui est venue
le rejoindre pendant ses heures sombres.
C'était quelqu'un qui avait fait d'Eva Braun son
secret d'État pour la bonne et simple raison,
Qu'il considérait que lui, en tant
que Führer du peuple allemand,
Ne pouvait en aucun cas être avec une femme parce
qu'il désespérerait en fait toutes les autres femmes,
D'être avec lui et qu'en même temps
il se le devait à son pays,
Ce qui considérait la notion de son pays et non pas à une femme, c'est pour ça que c'était devenu un secret absolu.
Mais il refuse d'aller se réfugier dans les Alpes
ou des troupes d'élite seraient stationnées.
Tous l'encouragent pourtant à aller en Bavière,
dans la soi disant forteresse des Alpes,
Où d'importantes fortifications et bunkers auraient
été construits dans la région de l'Obersalzberg.
La propagande allemande essaie de faire croire
aux Alliés que s'organise un réduit alpin,
D'où des éléments fanatisés de la SS pourraient tenir
la dragée haute aux alliés pendant encore longtemps.
Tout cela n'existe pas, tout cela est du vent.
Tout cela est de la propagande qu'Eisenhower croit d'ailleurs et ça a une incidence militaire très importante,
Parce qu'une grosse partie des forces américaines
vont être dirigées vers le sud, vers Munich et les Alpes,
Au lieu de la diriger vers l'ouest.
Hitler, lui, le sait, qu'il n'y a pas de réduit alpin,
Il sait donc que c'est reculer pour mieux sauter,
Il décide qu'il vaut mieux mourir avec une vaste
mise en scène du type wagnérien, apocalyptique,
Qui consiste à mourir avec ses
dernières troupes dans Berlin.
Speer, l'avait persuadé d'orchestrer de façon quasi cinématographique une fin grandiose et tragique à Berlin,
Plutôt qu'une fin pathétique à Berchtesgaden.
Et contre l'avis de tout son état major et de
ses proches, Hitler décide de rester à Berlin.
Vaincre ou mourir, c'est dans sa capitale
qu'il veut livrer sa dernière bataille.
Dans la nuit, cet anniversaire s'achève par le
dernier raid de l'aviation alliée sur Berlin.
Au petit matin du 21 avril, pour la première
fois depuis le début de la guerre,
Ce sont des obus de l'artillerie soviétique
qui s'abattent sur la ville hébétée.
C'est le scénario qui n'avait pas
été prévu, une bataille pour Berlin.
Il est évident qu'Hitler veut y jouer
une sorte de remake de Stalingrad.
Il se souvient, comme Goebbels, qu'il voit toutes
les nuits, qui lui rappelle sans arrêt ce précédent,
Que finalement, une grande bataille urbaine
peut provoquer un nouveau tournant de la guerre,
Et Staline d'accord à distance avec Hitler, décide
que oui, symboliquement, prendre Berlin a du sens.
Celui qui prend Berlin pour l'éternité et pour
l'histoire sera le vrai vainqueur du Reich.
Après les obus, les différents corps d'armée
soviétiques commencent leur encerclement de Berlin.
Il se trouvent à dix kilomètres du centre ville.
Les premiers soldats soviétiques pénètrent
dans le centre de la capitale allemande.
Staline a fixé comme objectif
symbolique la prise du Parlement.
À ce stade de l'avancée des Russes,
Hitler n'est pas encore sa priorité.
D'ailleurs, les services de renseignement soviétiques ne savent pas où il se trouve. Hitler pourrait avoir fui.
Pourtant, il est bien là, dans le bunker, à quelques mètres sous terre, ou il tente de planifier une contre offensive.
Il changeait d'état d'une minute à l'autre
et les briefings militaires dans le bunker,
Étaient totalement déconnectés de toute réalité.
Hitler commentait les cartes en
parlant d'armée et de division,
Alors qu'en fait il ne restait plus
que quelques hommes en armes.
Terré dans son bunker, il reste à
Hitler trois corps d'armée autour de Berlin.
La neuvième armée du général Busse au Sud-Est,
Le Corps Steiner au nord et la 12ᵉ armée
au sud-ouest de la ville.
Il n'y avait plus de véhicule blindé,
il n'y avait plus d'armes antichars,
Il n'y avait plus que de très jeunes soldats,
très motivés et prêts à se battre jusqu'à la fin,
Mais il n'y avait tout simplement
plus l'armement suffisant,
Et l'idée d'Hitler, que sa douzième armée
pourrait rejoindre la neuvième venant de l'Est,
Et lançait une vaste contre offensive contre
l'Armée rouge, était de l'ordre du fantasme.
Mais Hitler, lui, continuait à donner des ordres,
comme si ces trois forces pouvaient opérer,
Une sorte de mouvement concentrique permettant
finalement de contre encercler les armées soviétiques.
Aucune contre offensive ne réussit,
les Allemands reculent de toute part,
Hitler ne comprend pas que les troupes qu'il
déplace sur la carte ne percent pas.
Ce jour là, pour la première fois depuis longtemps,
Hitler perd toute contenance devant tout le monde.
Il fait une crise de colère dans laquelle il crie "J'abandonne, tout est perdu, c'est la fin."
C'est à ce moment là que tout son entourage
réalise qu'il n'a plus aucune solution,
Aucun plan ni espoir, que tout est vraiment perdu.
Ce désespoir, Eva Braun le partage avec Hitler.
Elle le décrit dans ce document exceptionnel,
également dévoilé pour la première fois.
Sa dernière lettre, qu'elle rédige le 22 avril, est
adressée à sa meilleure amie, Herta Schneider.
"Vraisemblablement, ce seront les dernières
lignes et mon dernier signe de vie,
Je n'ose pas l'écrire à Gretl, alors ce sera
à toi de le lui dire, avec ménagement."
Ils ont décidé l'un et l'autre de suicider.
Donc, c'est déjà très important puisque Hitler ne
va pas l'annoncer le 22 avril à son entourage,
Ils vont l'annoncer après. En tous les cas,
elle explique bien dans cette lettre,
La volonté qu'ils ont tous les deux de se suicider.
"Je vous enverrai mes bijoux que je
te prie de distribuer selon mon testament,
Ce que j'éprouve et souffre personnellement
pour le Führer, je ne peux pas te le décrire,
Je ne peux pas comprendre comment tout peut se terminer comme ça. Mais on ne peut plus croire en aucun Dieu.
Je crains que la fin n'approche.
Je meure comme j'ai vécu.
Garde pour toi cette lettre jusqu'à
ce que vous appreniez notre fin,
Je sais que je te demande beaucoup,
mais tu es courageuse."
Lui dit qu'elle va lui envoyer en même temps ses bijoux
et lui demande de prendre soin que son testament,
Elle a fait un testament qui est très
clair et qui est très détaillé,
Lui demande de faire en sorte que ce testament soit
tout simplement exécuté dans les moindres détails.
Cette lettre, le testament et les bijoux d'Eva Braun
partent le jour même pour la Bavière.
De son côté, le soir du 22, Hitler fait une
déclaration aux membres de son état major,
Dont fait partie le représentant de Goering.
Maintenant, je passe la main, c'est terminé, mon
successeur va s'en occuper. Goering n'a qu'à le faire.
En 1939 et 1941, le maréchal Goering avait été
nommé par décret, successeur potentiel.
Mais pour être appliqué, ces décrets doivent
être officialisés par une signature du Führer.
Les propos d'Hitler sont rapportés
à Goering, installé en Bavière,
Où il s'est mis à l'abri avec une partie de son
état major et Hans Lammers, un de ses conseillers.
Prudent, Goering, le dauphin, est d'abord dubitatif.
Est-ce que le décret du Führer qui
me nomme son dauphin, 39 reprit en 41,
Est-ce que ce décret est toujours valable ?
Est-ce qu'il y en a eu un autre depuis ? Et Lammers dit
non, s'il y en avait eu un autre, j'aurais été au courant.
Donc il est toujours valable, on le sort,
il le regarde, il médite dessus,
Il dit bon, si le Führer a dit ça et étant donné
que je suis le dauphin, qu'est-ce qu'on fait ?
Hermann Goering prend le temps de la réflexion.
Il est tiraillé entre ses délires de grandeur et la perspective de commettre une énorme faute politique.
Il décide de laisser passer la nuit.
À Berlin les bombardements se poursuivent.
Le 23 avril à l'aube et en prenant tous les risques, Albert Speer, l'architecte et ministre de L'armement d'Hitler,
Revient dans la capitale du Reich et descend dans le bunker.
Eva Braun est heureuse et pense qu'il va
réussir à convaincre le Führer de partir.
Elle se trompent lourdement.
Hitler a fait sa fortune comme architecte, lui
a donné accès aux plus hautes fonctions de l'État,
Mais néanmoins, avec un certain courage, il vient
présenter ses adieux, Hitler le reçoit assez froidement,
Mais comprend, Hitler n'est pas dupe, il voit
bien qu'autour de lui, tout le monde le lâche.
Albert Speer vient faire ses adieux à l'homme qu'il
admire et bien aussi lui faire un aveu de taille,
Il a désobéi. Speer n'a pas
appliqué l'ordre terrible d'Hitler,
Qui exige la destruction totale des infrastructures
du Reich devant l'Armée rouge et les Alliés.
Speer a été très touché par le manque
d'affection et d'attention d'Hitler.
Le Führer n'a même pas réagi lorsque
Speer lui avoue sa trahison,
En n'ayant pas respecté les ordres qu'il lui avait donné.
Et c'est là que l'on retrouve, dans cet ultime moment,
Un écho de cette relation spéciale
qui existait entre les deux hommes.
Speer a voulu le lui dire, mais en même temps,
il voulait revoir, une dernière fois, cet homme,
Pour lequel il avait eu un sentiment très fort,
Et Hitler voyait un peu dans Speer une
sorte de fils qu'il n'avait pas eu,
Et ce qui explique cette absence de réaction,
cette passivité face aux déclarations de Speer.
D'autres ont été fusillés pour beaucoup
moins, Hitler le laisse repartir.
En fin de journée, ce 23 avril 1945, Hermann Goering a
enfin pris sa décision. À 17h43, il écrit à Hitler.
"Mon Führer, êtes vous d'accord après votre
décision de demeurer à votre poste de combat,
Dans la forteresse de Berlin, pour
que je prenne la direction du Reich,
Avec pleins pouvoirs à l'intérieur et à l'extérieur ?"
Goering se dit qu'il aimerait bien,
il a d'ailleurs pris pas mal de contacts,
Pour essayer de signer des pourparlers de paix.
Goering souhaite le faire parce qu'il veut apparaître
comme l'homme qui a amené la paix à l'Allemagne,
Et il envoie un télégramme à Hitler au bunker, dans
lequel il lui dit que si, avant 22h, le 23 avril,
Hitler ne donne pas signe de vie, Goering considérera qu'ipso facto, il est le nouveau chancelier,
Et qu'Hitler n'est plus en mesure
de pouvoir donner ses volontés.
Ce télégramme est toute la correspondance qui va suivre,
Sont extraits des documents découverts par
le commandant Rose dans le bunker d'Hitler.
Ce sont en tout 13 lettres et télégrammes
originaux d'une portée historique,
Qui permettent aujourd'hui de retracer avec précision
ce dernier échange d'une tension extrême,
Entre Hitler et Goering.
Et puis il envoie un deuxième télégramme, cette
fois à Ribbentrop et probablement à Keitel aussi,
En leur disant : "S'il n'y a pas eu de réponse
du Führer, venez me retrouver à Berchtesgaden."
Ça veut dire, je reprends la succession.
Il n'a absolument pas le sentiment
d'être déloyal envers Hitler.
Il prend acte d'une situation qui est celle où Hitler
n'est plus en position de gouverner l'Allemagne.
Donc s'il prenait, s'il le remplaçait,
dans son esprit, ce serait un intérim.
Quelles que soient les intentions de Goering,
ce deuxième message va lui coûter très cher.
Lorsqu'il est remis à Hitler, ce dernier est entouré de Goebbels et Bormann, les plus farouches ennemis de Goering.
Goering avait largement sous estimé la façon dont Bormann, son ennemi de toujours, allait se servir de ce message.
Bormann l'a présenté à Hitler de telle façon qu'on ne pouvait l'interpréter que comme une trahison scandaleuse.
Et à ce stade de la guerre, Hitler était en plus
persuadé que l'unique raison de cette défaite,
Était due aux multiples trahisons de son entourage.
Le soir même, Hitler fait envoyer une
réponse cinglante à Hermann Goering.
"Le décret n'entre en vigueur
qu'après ma ratification extraordinaire.
Il ne saurait s'agir de me
dépouiller de ma liberté d'action.
J'interdis donc toute démarche de votre
part dans une quelconque direction."
Signé Adolf Hitler.
Sur recommandation de Bormann, son chef d'état major personnel, Hitler fait mettre Goering aux arrêts.
À 0h56, le 24 avril, Goering lui
répond par un long télégramme,
Dans lequel il se défend de toute mauvaise intention.
"Je n'ai rien entrepris jusqu'au reçu de votre réponse et me tiens à vos ordres.
Dieu vous protège encore. Votre fidèle Hermann Goering.
Je vous prie de donner ordre à Frank
de ne pas procéder à mon arrestation.
Je vous donne ma parole d'honneur
de m'être tenu strictement à vos ordres."
En cette fin de matinée du 24, Hitler dicte
un nouveau télégramme à l'adresse de Goering.
Signé de sa main, ce télégramme est sans équivoque.
"Vos actes constituent une trahison à la cause nationale. Une telle conduite, qui s'appelle haute trahison,
Mérite la peine de mort. Prenons en
considération vos grands services passés,
Je vous donne la possibilité de démissionner
en invoquant le motif d'une grave maladie.
Je vous somme de répondre immédiatement par oui ou non."
Dans les minutes qui suivent, Goering
répond par oui à la demande du Führer.
Il démissionne de toutes ses
fonctions pour raisons de santé.
C'est l'accession au pouvoir, quelque part d'un
personnage de l'ombre qui s'appelait Martin Bormann,
Qui est son secrétaire depuis que
Rudolf Hess est parti en 41 en Angleterre,
Et Bormann va donner libre cours à la détestation
qu'il peut avoir de certaines personnalités,
Et va essayer d'appuyer en vérité son pouvoir.
Goering est catastrophé, mais pour
Bormann, ce n'est pas suffisant.
Bormann, qui dispose de son propre
centre de communication au sein du bunker,
Va profiter de la disgrâce de Goering
pour faire avancer ses pions.
Sans en référer à Hitler, il donne un ordre sans
appel à l'officier chargé de le surveiller.
Bormann lui donne l'ordre de les exécuter, tous,
Une fois que Berlin sera tombé. Alors
ce scénario ne va pas se réaliser,
Parce que le commandant SS qui avait été chargé
de cette mission, une fois que Berlin tombe,
Considère que cet assassinat n'a plus grand sens,
n'aurait plus grand sens, donc ne va pas exécuter l'ordre.
Alors pourquoi après la chute de Berlin ?
Bah après la chute de Berlin,
Parce qu'il sait qu'Hitler ne sera plus
vivant donc il pourra régler ses comptes.
Son idée, c'est que, bon il sait
que Goebbels va suivre Hitler,
Donc il se dit après ça, si je me débarrasse
aussi de Goering, il n'y aura plus que moi.
Hitler ignore ce qui se trame dans son dos.
Et pour humilier encore plus Goering il
le dépouille de ses derniers pouvoirs.
Le 25 avril, il dicte un ultime message à
son assistante, à l'attention de Goering.
"En raison de votre attitude infidèle au peuple
allemand, à ma personne et aux mesures envisagées,
Je vous chasse du parti."
Signé à la main par Adolf Hitler.
Ce jour là, il ordonne également la destruction
de toutes ses archives personnelles.
Ces documents auraient dû être détruits mais dans la panique des derniers jours, ils ont été miraculeusement oubliés.
Hitler a fait brûler l'intégralité de ses archives privées.
Donc on peut penser à certaines correspondances fort importantes qu'il a pu avoir avec des chefs d'État,
Il a fait aussi brûler l'intégralité des
notes d'états majors qui étaient là,
Et il a d'ailleurs demandé aussi à son adjudant,
Julius Schaub, de ne pas s'arrêter là,
Mais de quitter le bunker pour aller brûler ses
archives à Munich, dans son appartement,
Et brûler ses archives à Berchtesgaden,
ce que Schaub a fait.
Il y a une préoccupation, un petit peu comme Goebbels,
il y a une préoccupation de sa postérité.
Les combats se rapprochent.
Les troupes soviétiques progressent d'heure en heure.
Les obus tombent désormais sans arrêt dans les jardins
de la Chancellerie, juste au dessus du bunker.
Une série de notes dactylographiées retranscrivant
des discussions entre Hitler et Goebbels,
Nous éclairent sur les derniers
espoirs militaires du Führer.
Ces documents ont été conservés par Heinz Lorenz,
qui dirigeait le service de presse du bunker.
Ils ont été publiés récemment, on peut y lire :
"C'est ici, à Berlin, que je peux remporter une
victoire. Si je l'obtient, ne fusse que morale,
On aura au moins l'occasion de sauver
la face et de gagner du temps."
"À Berlin, on peut obtenir un succès
qui aurait une portée mondiale.
Ce succès ne peut être obtenu qu'à l'endroit
où les yeux du monde entier sont braqués."
"Il ne peut y avoir de retournement que si
j'inflige un revers au colosse bolchévique.
Alors les autres finiront peut-être par se convaincre qu'il n'y en a qu'un qui est en mesure d'arrêter ce colosse.
Moi, le parti et l'état allemand."
Toutes ces armées soviétiques de façon concentrique
avancent vers le Reichstag et la Chancellerie,
Qui ne se trouvent pas très loin.
Pour les civils, c'est un calvaire qui n'en finit pas.
Vous vous imaginez les caves complètement bondées,
Il n'y a plus d'eau, il n'y a plus de téléphone,
L'alimentation devient un problème dramatique,
Dès qu'un cheval est tué dans la rue, les gens
se précipitent pour découper un peu de viande,
Au péril de leur vie.
C'est au milieu de ce déluge de feu qu'une
femme, un as de l'aviation allemande,
Réussit à poser son avion à quelques pas du bunker d'Hitler.
Nous sommes le 27 avril, Hanna Reitsch, une nazie convaincue, et son amant, le général Ritter von Greim,
Veulent rencontrer Hitler de toute urgence.
Ils descendent dans le bunker, Ritter von Greim
est allongé sur une civière,
Il a pris une balle dans le pied lors de l'atterrissage.
Alors pourquoi vient-elle ? Et bien pour essayer
de convaincre Hitler de quitter le bunker,
Et de partir peut-être pour Berchtesgaden.
Évidemment, Hanna Reitsch ne peut rien faire,
Surtout pas convaincre un Hitler qui
refuse catégoriquement de quitter Berlin.
C'est d'ailleurs à ce moment précis qu'il se
décide à distribuer des capsules de cyanure,
À une partie de son entourage.
Il en offre une à Reitsch, à qui il
parle longuement du suicide.
Cette distribution de capsules de cyanure, est d'ailleurs
un symbole de distinction qu'il lui accorde.
Il la récompense pour cet exploit.
Capsule de cyanure pour Hanna Reitsch
et promotion pour Ritter von Greim,
Qui est nommé général en chef de
l'armée de l'air à la place de Goering.
Puis ils repartent comme ils sont arrivés en décollant
sous le feu soviétique. Ils s'en sortiront vivant.
Pendant ce temps, un autre dignitaires nazis
s'active en coulisses, Heinrich Himmler.
Il a quitté Berlin juste après l'anniversaire d'Hitler.
Le ministre de l'Intérieur du Reich et
chef des SS offre en secret aux Alliés,
Une capitulation sans condition de l'Allemagne nazie.
Sûr de son coup, Himmler tente de prendre la main.
Les Alliés l'assassine médiatiquement le 28 avril.
Et Eisenhower a opposé un refus, un refus complet,
Le communiqué par lequel il répond négativement
est publié dans la presse occidentale.
Hitler est hystérique, il démet de toutes ses fonctions l'homme qui a orchestré pour lui la solution finale.
Sa dernière trahison de l'un de ses
plus proches le rend fou de rage.
Toujours présent dans Berlin mais hors
du bunker, le général SS Hermann Fegelein,
Est l'officier de liaison d'Himmler auprès d'Hitler.
Hitler était d'humeur à la vengeance.
Et l'on peut dire que le fait que Fegelein
était sur le point de fuir Berlin,
Qu'il était en plus soupçonné d'être directement
associé à Himmler dans cet acte de trahison,
Le conduit à le faire fusiller.
Le général Fegelein est aussi le beau-frère d'Eva Braun.
Il est marié à sa sœur Gretl et Hitler
avait assisté en personne à leur mariage.
Eva Braun n'était pas prête à
prendre la défense de Fegelein.
Elle était même horrifiée qu'il planifiait une désertion, qu'il était sur le point d'abandonner le Führer.
Elle qui avait fait le choix de rester
jusqu'au bout, considérait la fuite de Fegelein,
Comme un acte d'une grande lâcheté,
qui plus est avec sa maîtresse.
Pour Eva Braun, c'était même donc une double trahison
car cet homme était marié à sa sœur Gretl.
Hitler accuse le coup sur le plan psychologique.
Dans une dernière conversation scénographié et
conservée par l'officier de presse Heinz Lorenz,
Hitler et Goebbels discutent sans grande
conviction de la situation militaire.
Si seulement Funk pouvait arriver.
"Je vais essayer de m'allonger un peu.
Je ne vais être réveillé que si un blindé
russe se présente devant le bunker,
Afin que j'aie le temps de prendre mes dispositions.
À présent, c'est à moi d'obéir aux ordres du destin.
Même si je pouvais me sauver. Je ne le ferai pas.
Le capitaine ne quitte pas le navire qui sombre."
Hitler et Goebbels pensent sans trop d'espoir
que la 12ᵉ armée du général Wenck,
Est sur le point de briser l'encerclement du
centre de Berlin, c'est le contraire qui se produit.
A peine arrivé, ce qu'il reste de
la 12ᵉ armée se retire dans le chaos.
Les soupapes d'échappement de cette population,
ça va être les rumeurs et les fausses nouvelles.
Par exemple, le 28 avril, une pluie
de tracts s'abat sur Berlin,
Où on annonce que l'armée Wenck arrive,
elle arrive du sud-ouest,
Donc c'est une armée allemande qui vient
briser l'étau de fer des troupes soviétiques,
C'est évidemment un bobard, l'armée Wenck est déjà
en train de se faire refouler de Potsdam,
Elle n'arrivera jamais dans Berlin même.
On croit tout ce qui traîne et puis
au bout d'un moment, c'est l'apathie,
La peur, le désir de vivre 1h, 2h, 3h de plus.
Le 29 avril 1945, à 1h du matin, Hitler épouse
Eva Braun, sa maîtresse depuis treize ans.
Seuls témoins présents de cette union, Goebbels,
Bormann et un officier d'état civil.
Un acte de mariage est signé
par les mariés et leurs témoins.
Hitler précise que c'est à la demande d'Eva Braun
qu'a lieu cette cérémonie surréaliste,
Compte tenu des circonstances.
Je pense qu'Hitler se décide à épouser
Eva Braun pour plusieurs raisons.
La première, en partie à cause de
toutes les trahisons de ses proches,
Ensuite, la décision d'Eva Braun de le rejoindre
pour mourir à ses côtés doit être récompensée.
Il savait en outre que son vœu le plus
cher était de devenir Madame Hitler.
On peut aussi y voir un autre
sens, le sens, la confirmation,
Hitler a compris que la partie était perdue. Pourquoi ?
Parce que dans les jours heureux, au fond
je n'ai qu'une seule épouse, l'Allemagne,
Et au nom de ce grand principe, eh bien,
il refusait de se marier.
Après un verre de mousseux avec Eva Braun
et le dernier carré de fidèles,
Hitler se retire dans la salle de réunion et
appelle sa secrétaire Traudl Junge.
Il lui dicte rapidement son testament politique.
Sans hésitation et sans correction.
Il n'avait tiré aucune leçon de ses échecs.
Il campe sur les mêmes positions,
toujours totalement obsédé par les juifs,
Persuadé qu'il n'a jamais eu tort, qu'il n'a commis aucune erreur et que tout ça se résume à une affaire de trahison.
On sait que c'est un anti-sémite patenté, pathologique,
Et il dit je suis tombé en victime des
deux visages de la juiverie internationale,
Son visage judéo bolchévique à l'est et le visage
de la finance juive internationale à l'ouest.
Alors que se joue dans le bunker le
dernier acte de la tragédie hitlérienne,
L'Armée rouge lance sa dernière grande offensive.
Les Soviétiques s'arrêtent sans le savoir à 500 mètres
du bunker d'Hitler, car ils en ignorent l'existence.
Ils ne savent pas non plus si le
Führer est présent à Berlin,
Ils pensent que tous les hauts dignitaires nazis
sont dans le bâtiment du Parlement, le Reichstag.
Leur cible, c'est le Reichstag. En d'autres termes,
il aurait pu encore rester 2 jours dans son bunker,
Personne ne se serait aperçu de rien.
Les Soviétiques, une fois qu'ils ont pris le Reichstag,
ils s'attendaient à trouver tout le gouvernement là,
Ils l'ont pas trouvé, mais c'était leur but.
Le 30 avril dans son testament privé
dicté à 3h du matin, Hitler annonce :
"Moi-même et mon épouse choisissons la mort. Pour échapper
à la honte de la destitution ou de la capitulation.
Notre volonté est d'être brûlé immédiatement et sur place."
Hitler ne voulait absolument pas que son corps puisse
être exhibé par les Russes comme un symbole ou un trophée.
C'est pourquoi il a exigé que son corps
et celui d'Eva Braun soient brûlés ensemble.
J'ai pu lire dans les archives russes un document
barré du symbole du Führer à l'intention d'Hitler,
Dans lequel la mort de Mussolini lui est décrite.
Hitler était déterminé à ne pas finir
pendu comme l'a été Mussolini en Italie,
C'est pourquoi il exige que son
corps soit totalement détruit.
Le 30 avril 1945, en début d'après-midi, après
avoir fait empoisonner sa chienne Blondi,
Hitler fait ses adieux à tous ses collaborateurs.
À ses assistantes, il conseille la fuite vers l'Ouest.
À ses officiers de continuer le combat.
Hitler et Eva Braun se retirent
à 15h dans leurs appartements.
Les corps d'Eva Braun et Hitler sont immédiatement
brûlés dans les jardins de la chancellerie,
Juste devant l'une des sorties du bunker.
Le lendemain, 1ᵉʳ mai, Magda et Joseph Goebbels se
suicide par balle après avoir empoisonné leurs 6 enfants.
La Seconde Guerre mondiale se termine comme
elle a commencé selon la volonté d'Hitler.
Pour sa renommée posthume, il a choisi le final
collectif grandiose de la bataille de Berlin,
À sa propre mort, il ne s'est
résolu qu'au tout dernier moment,
48h avant l'entrée des soldats soviétiques
dans le bunker, le 2 mai 1945 à 15h.
Sur le terrain, les opérations militaires
se poursuivent pendant une semaine,
Jusqu'aux signatures de la capitulation
allemande les 7 et 8 mai à Reims et à Berlin.
Le régime nazi survit jusqu'au 23 mai, le Führer disparut, la pression se relâche et tout s'arrête très vite.
Mais que devient le corps d'Hitler ?
Et qui le découvre en premier ?
Les gens du SMERSH vont récupérer et vont trouver
l'endroit qui a été recouvert de terre,
Où se trouve le corps d'Hitler et d'Eva Braun,
Ils vont les sortir de terre, ils vont
les mettre dans des caisses en bois,
Et ils vont aller faire, puisque les corps
sont carbonisés mais pas complètement détruits,
Et ils vont aller faire des autopsies, ils
vont bien évidemment vérifier sa dentition.
Et Hitler avait un bridge très particulier,
il détestait aller chez le dentiste,
Il avait un bridge très particulier à nul autre pareil
qui avait été fait spécialement pour lui en or.
Une fois les restes du corps formellement identifiés par
les services secrets soviétiques, la mystification commence.
Staline n'informe pas le maréchal Joukov, vainqueur de la bataille de Berlin, de la découverte du corps de Hitler.
Il sait qu'Hitler est mort, il ne le dit pas Joukov,
Ce qui fait que lorsque Joukov, qui a
pris le Reichstag et qui est désigné,
Même si Koniev a aussi une part
comme le vainqueur de Berlin,
Lorsque Joukov va faire la fameuse conférence de
presse devant devant les journalistes du monde entier,
Il va dire devant le monde entier,
on n'a pas retrouvé le cadavre d'Hitler,
On ne peut donc pas exclure qu'il se soit enfui.
C'est paradoxal parce que Staline sait
parfaitement qu'il ne s'est pas enfui,
Mais le monde entier va retenir cette phrase incroyable.
Et si Hitler n'était pas mort et s'il s'était enfui...
C'est le point de départ de tous les
fantasmes sur le sort d'Hitler.
Cette omission de Staline alimente pendant au moins 30
ans toute une littérature pseudo historique délirante.
Des centaines de livres, d'articles et de témoignages l'identifient un peu partout dans le monde,
Et notamment en Amérique latine.
Pourquoi Staline passe-t-il sous silence les
informations qu'il détient sur le corps d'Hitler ?
C'est un effet de la duplicité de Staline qui possède
une information qu'il ne va pas divulguer,
Parce qu'il va l'utiliser dans
sa propagande, périodiquement,
Pour faire planer le doute sur
une fuite d'Hitler à l'Ouest,
Et conforter son discours de la guerre froide qui consiste
à dire il n'y a qu'une puissance anti-fascistes au monde,
C'est l'Union soviétique, la preuve
c'est que peut-être Hitler est vivant,
Et il est caché par les Américains ou
par des affidés des Américains,
Donc c'est une arme de propagande et rien de plus.
Reste le bunker, qu'est-il devenu ?
A-t-il été détruit ?
Les lieux où Hitler a fini ses jours ne sont pas
devenus un mémorial pour les nostalgiques du Reich.
Après la chute du mur de Berlin en 1989, l'occident
découvre que les anciens jardins de la chancellerie,
Sous lesquels était construit le bunker, sont devenus
un parking pour les résidents de ces barres d'immeubles.
Ce n'est que 70 ans plus tard qu'une association
berlinoise a pu faire installer ce panneau,
Qui raconte avec précision l'histoire des
derniers jours d'Hitler dans son bunker.
À ce jour, les autorités soviétiques n'ont
toujours pas donné d'explications,
Sur ce qui a été fait des restes du corps.
Quant aux documents historiques découverts par le commandant Rose et Bruno Ledoux, le collectionneur français,
Ils sont maintenant publics.
Ils permettent aujourd'hui de compléter certains
aspects fondamentaux de l'histoire politique et privée,
Du plus grand criminel du XXᵉ siècle.